Buenas noches de nuevo Ucrania vuelve a
ser uno de los temas principales de esta
cumbre de líderes europeos en Bruselas
en que los jefes de estadio de gobierno
acordaron dar compromisos de seguridad a
Ucrania a largo plazo los líderes no han
querido detallar exactamente de qué tipo
de compromisos de seguridad te trataría
pero sí insisten en la importancia de
seguir apoyando a Ucrania de forma
financiera y también militarmente pero
también en la reconstrucción los líderes
europeos han pedido a la comisión
europea que ponga sobre la mesa una
propuesta concreta con que en que haya
una base legal sobre Cómo utilizar los
bienes congelados del Banco Central de
Rusia aproximadamente unos tres mil
millones de dólares que se encuentran en
Europa para que contribuyan a la
reconstrucción de Ucrania desde Bruselas
se considera que los contribuyentes
europeos no deberían pagar por la
destrucción hecha por Rusia en
territorio ucraniano los líderes
europeos también han hablado por con el
presidente ucraniano zelensky en que han
abordado esta cuestión y también la
futura negociaciones para que Ucrania
pueda ser miembro de la Unión Europea
los líderes europeos tienen aún que ver
a finales de años y se han hecho
suficientes avances desde las capitales
europeas se considera que sí que ha
vivido avances pero aún hay que ver si
son suficientes para abrir estas
negociaciones a finales de año tal y
como pide el presidente ucraniano los
líderes no han podido obviar la
situación en Rusia que consideran que
ahora mismo el régimen de Vladimir Putin
es más frágil tras el motín organizado
por el grupo Wagner el pasado fin de
semana pero que a la vez seguirán
estando vigilantes a pesar de que es un
asunto interno de Rusia sobre todo
porque según alertan Fuentes europeas
Están preocupados de que puede haber un
cóctel explosivo aseguran estas Fuentes
en que hay una narrativa nuclear por
parte del kremlin pero a la vez también
una presencia del grupo Wagner en la
reunión de hoy que se ha centrado sobre
todo en estas relaciones exteriores pero
también en la migración continuará
mañana con un capítulo económico y sobre
todo con las relaciones comerciales y de
inversión con China